it was just an ordinary Saturday
my dad was outside mowing the lawn my
mom was upstairs folding laundry my
sister was in a room doing homework and
I was in the basement playing video
games and as I came upstairs to get
something to drink
I looked out the window and realized
there was something that was supposed to
be doing and this is what I saw no this
wasn't my family's dinner on fire
this was my science project flames were
pouring out smoke was in the air and it
looked like a wooden death was about to
catch fire I immediately started yelling
my mom was freaking out my dad ran
around to put out the fire and of course
my sister started recording a snapchat
video this was just the beginning of my
teens science project my team is
composed of me and three other students
here here in the audience today we
competed in FIRST LEGO League which is
an international Lego robotics
competition for kids in in addition to
robotics game we also worked on a
separate science project and this was
the project that we were working on so
the idea for this project all started
when a few months earlier a couple fly
teammates took a trip to Central America
and saw beaches littered with styrofoam
or expanded polystyrene foam and when
they came back and told us about it
we really started thinking about the
ways in which we see styrofoam every day
get a new flat-screen TV you end up with
a block of styrofoam bigger than the TV
itself drink a cup of coffee with those
styrofoam coffee cups are sure going to
add up and worry all these items go
after their one-time use since there are
any good existing solutions for use
styrofoam almost all of them end up
riding the landfill or the oceans and
beaches taking over 500 years to degrade
and in fact every year the US alone
produces over 2 billion pounds of
styrofoam filling up a staggering 25% of
landfills so why do we have these ghost
accumulations of styrofoam waste why
can't we just recycle
like many plastics well simply put
recycled polystyrene it's too expensive
and potentially contaminated so there is
very little market demand for styrofoam
it has to be recycled and as a result
styrofoam is considered an honourable
material because it is neither feasible
nor viable to recycle polystyrene and in
fact many cities across the u.s. have
even passed ordinances that simply ban
the production of many products
containing polystyrene which includes
disposable utensils packing peanuts
takeout containers and even plastic
beach toys all products were very useful
in today's society and now France has
become the first country to completely
ban all plastic utensils cups and plates
but what if we could keep using
styrofoam and keep benefiting from its
cheap lightweight insulating and
excellent packing ability while having
to suffer from the repercussions of
having to dispose of it what if we could
turn it into something else it's
actually useful what if we can make the
impossible possible
Mighty Mite pathi size that we could use
the carbon that is already in styrofoam
to create activated carbon which is used
in almost every water filter today an
activated carbon works by using very
small micro pores to filter out
contaminants from water or even air so
we started out by doing a variety of
heating tests and unfortunately we had
many failures literally nothing work
besides my dad's cool kitchen on fire
most of our samples vaporized into
nothing or exploded inside expensive
furnaces leaving a horribly sticky mess
in fact we were so saddened by our
failures that we almost gave up so why
did we keep trying when all the adults
said it was impossible
well maybe it's because we're kids we
don't know any better but the truth is
we kept trying because we thought it was
still possible we knew this we were
successful we will be hoping the
environment and making the world a
better place so we kept trying and
failing and trying and failing
we were so ready to give up but then it
happened
with the right temperatures times and
chemicals we finally got
successful test result showing us that
we had created activity carbon from
started from waste and at that moment
the thing that have been impossible
all of a sudden wasn't it showed us that
although we have many failures at the
beginning we were able to persevere
through them to get the test results
that we wanted and moreover not only
were we able to create activity carbon
for purifying water but we were also
able to reduce styrofoam waste solving
to global problems with just one
solution so from then on we were
inspired to take our project further
performing more tests to make it more
effective in testing it in real-world
situations we then proceeded to receive
funding from the nstac cyber mission
stem and action program sponsored by the
US Army as well as first global
Innovation Awards sponsored by XPrize
and we were also honored with a site
with the Scientific American innovator
award from Google science fair and using
these funds we plan to file a full
patent on our process and to continue to
work on our project so yes although we
started with fillings with sketching my
dad's grill on fire in filling so many
times that we almost quit it was well
worth it when we look back in it now we
took a problem the many people said was
impossible and we made it possible and
we persevered when it looked like
nothing that we did work we learned you
can't have success without a little or a
lot of failure so in the future don't be
afraid if your grill goes up in flames
because you never know when your idea
might just catch fire
[Applause]